[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
nächste woche ist schon ostern und ob
man jetzt ostern feiert oder nicht finde
ich dass eine frühjahrs worte jetzt sehr
passend ist dazu habe ich mir was
überlegt nämlich eine torte mit blumen
und schönen obendrauf
ich denke sie wieder auch recht schön so
wie ich sie machen möchte
ich habe mir überlegt dass ich eine
zitrone und mond hatte mache ich habe
heute morgen eine abstimmung gemacht auf
instagram ich guck mal nach denn wir
hatten hier im team so das gespräch
wachstum magst du keinen mond also ich
bin der totale mondfinsternis mit
zitrone und zum beispiel früchten finde
ich es mir gut ich mag es aber auch
gerne als mohnkuchen oder aber ich habe
mal diesen türkischen mondkuchen gemacht
dann ist ihr problem der ist so lecker
und ich mag es auch als stollen oder als
mond strebt habe ich auch schon gemacht
das ist sehr lecker mit hefeteig und
dann von der mond füllung also ich mag
es ganz gerne
ich guck mal kurz nach der abstimmung
weil dementsprechend kann ich jetzt
dastehen lassen oder weg machen
bitte sag ja bitte sag ja sie haben post
tourismus
also 72 prozent sagen sie mögen meinen
mann hat gewonnen
ich persönlich mag nicht sogar an gehört
zur minderheit 22 profis keine montag
mononatriumglutamat mache ich auch nicht
und mon cheri mich auch nicht alles was
mit mond an fink mag ich nicht
ja es schreibt mal alles gleich
mitnehmen
schade dann darfst du die torte nicht
probieren
ich frage in meinem team dämonen mag
aber auch wenn ihr keinen mögt ich bin
dafür alle da und möchte da keine
fronten schaffen wenn ihr keinen monat
könnt ihr ihn weglassen ihr könnt ja
einfach austauschen durch gemahlene
mandeln zum beispiel oder durch
haselnüsse oder durch kokosraspeln also
das bleibt wirklich euch überlassen
der teig den ich jetzt machen werde ist
ein rührteig aber nicht basierend auf
butter sondern mit öl
die zubereitung ist einfach ab und was
ich sagen wollte ich nehme jetzt gleich
ein bisschen raum dazu weil ich gerade
sei vielleicht noch im kühlschrank habe
das ist ja salzige so ein salziger
joghurtdrink den nehme ich ihr könnt
aber auch stattdessen milz oder
buttermilch verwenden sollte dann aber
der prise salz zufügen
ja ich sage euch mal kurz den zutaten
den ofen habe ich bereits auf 170 grad
ober unterhitze vorgeheizt ich verwende
dafür 6 300 gramm zucker etwas von den
extrakt 300 gramm
300 gramm sonnenblumenöl 400 gramm mehl
50 gramm weiße schokolade dies bereits
gerastet 100 gramm hohen ein päckchen
backpulver das sind drei teelöffel oder
etwas zitronen abrieb stadt hohen abrieb
könnt ihr aber auch zum beispiel strom
passte verwenden
auch damals zuschauer werden merken dass
hier nur fünf eier darin sind
staubsauger hatten grund ich habe
nämlich nur große eier und normalerweise
wird ja ein m also ungefähr 50 gramm
ohne schale manchmal mehr manchmal
weniger aber so ungefähr zwischen 45 und
50 gramm und ich rechne auch immer 1 1 m
größe
ich hatte jetzt leider nur deswegen habe
ich ein weniger genommen und kommen auf
die gleiche leier maße auf 300
ungefähr also deswegen lasst euch nicht
jetzt kann ich die eier in eine
rührschüssel geben
die sind bereits zimmer war das ist auch
gut und wichtig kam letztlich wurde -
aufschlagen lassen
der zucker kommt dazu und vanille
extrakt
[Musik]
dann die eier zucker masse etwa zehn
minuten schaumig aufschlagen bisher
wirklich schön dick cremig ist es geht
natürlich auch mit dem handrührgerät
daraus vielleicht sogar 15 minuten und
hier muss ich sagen in der
küchenmaschine vor allem mit dem großen
ballon schneebesen dauert wahrscheinlich
nur 50 minuten
ich mache auch auf dem blog und in der
app immer so etwa zeitangaben wie es
eben mit normalen geräten der hand rück
gerät zum beispiel oder im kochtopf und
deswegen sind es immer so durchschnitts
angaben für euch einfach darauf achten
dass sie wirklich schön die cremig ist
ich habe hier schon mal 2 back ringen
backpapier einschlagen ich mag jetzt
zwei gleichzeitig auf einem blech damit
ich von der höhe her eine hohe torte
bekommen ihr könnt aber auch den teig
nehmen ohne 26er torte zum beispiel
banken die wir dann flacher und größer
aber dann können wir darauf einmal
sacken weil das ist schon zu viel zeit
für eine 20 fr
aber ich fahre dinge und ich schlag dich
ziemlich backpapier 1 damit der teig
nicht ausläuft denn sie sichert es geht
übrigens am besten mit so griffigen
papier veranschlagen
das ende so rein knallen dann passen
zwei perfekt die zuckermasse sieht jetzt
auch super aus den adern gut
durchschütteln vorher und dazugeben und
ich brauche jetzt hier 300 gramm was
macht man mit dem anderen offenen
welcher der ja schon vorgemacht mehr
drin
das sonnenblumenöl auch dazu geben da
bin ein tipp für euch viele frage mich
welches sonnenblumenöl ich verwende ich
nehme da tatsächlich das günstigste denn
dieses bio sonne
das riecht man stark und das würde ich
zum backen eigentlich nicht verwenden
wenn man sowohl um geschmack mag kann
man es schon nehmen man kann es ja auch
mit erhitzen aber ich muss auch
geschmacklich finde ich das was eben
nicht nach sondern blumen schmeckt
einfach besser passt besser zum kuchen
so dass wir jetzt ganz kurz ein gerührt
bei niedriger stufe
lange mit ganze
frucht einlage und gesamtanlage heute
alles im video
schön dann kann ich hier die trockenen
zutaten vermischen mehl mit backpulver
monde das bild der weiße schokolade und
stehen zitronen abrieb einfach verrühren
damit sie das mehl mit dem backpulver
den übrigen zutaten gut vermischt und
bei den zitronen solltet ihr einfach
darauf achten dass er unbehandelte
zitrone nehmen die am besten noch bio
sind damit ihr die schale mit verzerren
könnte die schöne abreiben
ich habe auch immer ein großes gefäß der
ton abrieb im gefrierfach denn wenn ich
schon bio zitrone kaufe dann reibe ich
die auch meistens ab rest den saft aus
benutzt den unternehmen noch die schale
also diese ausgedrückte schale und legt
sie in die spülmaschine
das bringt zum einen einen schönen duft
also ein spülmaschinen und zitronen sind
ja auch kalk lösen also unterstützt auch
so diesen reinigungsprozess und falls
ihr keine zitronen habt die unbehandelt
sind könnt ihr auch immer auf zitronen
passt zum beispiel zurückgreifen da
müsst ihr einfach dass ihr die auch
bedenkenlos nehmen könnte die zutaten
kommen jetzt hier rein und werden ganz
groß eingerührt
normalerweise habe ich schon unterhalb
element aber das habe ich gerade nicht
getrunken
in meiner küche ja das hat bestimmt
irgendwo hin geräumt egal ich will es
ganz kurz
bei niedriger stufe 1
mit allein schon der anblick ist von süß
weil schon noch auf mono auf englisch
heißt hatten wir das mal gerne poppig
sie plötzlich schönes wohnen und jetzt
auf türkisch wirkliches rasch und jetzt
gleichmäßig auf die ringe aufteilen
[Musik]
dann gerne am rand so ein bisschen hoch
streichen damit der teig schön
gleichmäßig hoch klettern kann
jetzt kommt der kuchen im backofen
dauert so ungefähr 50 minuten ihr sollte
am besten nach 45 minuten mal ein
schnäppchen probe machen also einen
guard ist und ich schätze aber 50
brauche auf jeden fall
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich mich um
meine frucht anlage kümmern denn ich
finde darf zitrone mond perfekt zu
waldfrüchten passt macht am ende der
backzeit auf jeden fall ein stäbchen
probe wenn da nichts mehr dran hängen
bleibt dann ist der kuchen fertig ich
nehme mir jetzt raus und schloss ihn auf
einem abkühlt abkühlen
für die frucht ein lager verwende ich
500 gramm früchtetees sind tief
gefrorene das ist so eine waldfrucht
mischung und die nehme ich ganz gerne
weil sie einfach erntefrisch direkt
eingefroren werden und ich so die volle
süßes aus den früchten habe und momentan
gibt es eben noch keine frischen früchte
zumindest nicht regional dann verwende
ich eine tüte aka aka das ist ein
pflanzliches geliermittel ihr könnt auch
statine verwenden aber ich benutze immer
am liebsten agger und eine tüte also
manchmal ist es unterschiedlich ob es
dann zehn gramm oder 15 gramm sind ich
glaube bei bio sind es zehn kamen beim
anderen 15
es steht auf der rückseite dass die
menge für 500 milliliter flüssigkeit ist
und deswegen passt also eine tüte und 50
gramm wasser und falls ihr jetzt eine
kenwood habt dann könnt ihr auch die
frucht einlage dort einfach kochen
das ist auch ganz einfach du bist ja
auch nicht rühren ihr könnt die uhrzeit
einstellen
ich mache jetzt hier in topf damit ihr
das alle gut seht ich werde oft gefragt
warum ich nicht alles in der kennwort
mache wenn ich sie doch sowieso benutzer
und die antwort ist eigentlich ganz
einfach es hat halt nicht jeder eine
küchenmaschine mit koch funktion und ich
zeige es immer so dass es jeder
nachmachen kann wenn ich jetzt ohne
kamera kochen würde oder backen würde
dann würde ich schon da drin
weil ich eben nicht hören muss und ich
habe die einstellung ich muss nicht auf
die uhrzeit schauen aber so macht es
natürlich so dass er eben auch seht wie
es ohne geht nicht immer alles denn ich
muss ja auch oder möchte auch zeit
sparen
so jetzt hier die früchte einfach kochen
lassen ich drücke die dann auch ein
bisschen und kann auch schon mal das ag
mit dem wasser vermischen
[Musik]
frucht einlage so komplett zerdrücken
oder soll sie noch glücklich sein wenn
die früchte dann zerdrückt sind könnt
ihr auch direkt das acker mit rein geben
denn dieses sollte ryan bevor es kocht
es soll er mit kochen
damit ist auch nicht verklumpt und
sobald ihr mir schon kocht als ihr
dürfte jetzt so lange zu drücken wie ihr
möchtet oder mit dem pürierstab pürieren
ich lasse es aber ein bisschen stück ich
finde ich ganz schön und sobald kocht
einfach zwei minuten lang mindestens
sprudelnd kochen lassen damit eben das
ak seine wirkung entfalten kann
falls ihr mit gelatine arbeitet dann
sollte die relative vorher mit wasser
verrühren stehen lassen damit es eben
quellen kann die masse hier aufkochen
und dann abschalten und dann die
gelatine in der warmen wasser auflösen
also das ist der größte unterschied
zwischen gelatine und magazine das eben
statine nicht kochen da ansonsten
verliert sie ihre bilder eigenschaft und
agger die pflanzliche entity muss kochen
zwei minuten lang damit zu bindet
[Musik]
jetzt ist ihr maß es soweit und ich gebe
jetzt ein bisschen war es in einem
flachen teller
ich mache sozusagen eine lehrprobe ob
die masse auch wirklich fest wird und
wenn ihr das so macht selbst aufbringen
wenn ihr das so macht oder den
kühlschrank stellt dann seht ihr auch
innerhalb von 12 minuten
ob es fest wird wenn es fest wird ist
perfekt dann könnt ihr die masse
verwenden falls es nicht fest wird
sollte es hier noch mal kochen und in
der zeit kann das ja auch noch ein
bisschen abkühlen
so sieht die masse aus dieses bei mir
noch warm aber ich sehe schon sie wird
fest und das heißt die andere macht
damit auch schön fest die gebe ich
gerade wieder zurück sie löst die schon
da waren wir noch auf und um diese
frucht einlage jetzt in form zu bringen
nämlich einfach tiefe täler die habe ich
jetzt ausgelegt mit folie ich bin uns
eigentlich nicht so gern folie aber da
brauche ich sie leider ihr könnt aber
auch wenn ihr habt silikon formen zum
beispiel benutzen
es sollte nur relativ flach sein denn
ich möchte jetzt mich so eine beule in
der torte sondern wirklich eine schöne
flache frucht einlage und wichtig ist
auch dass die frucht einlage mindestens
5 cm kleiner ist im durchmesser als die
torte also maximal 15
ich mache jetzt fünf denn ich denke ich
habe später sechs bösen also überall so
ein bisschen was rein film
[Musik]
dann so ein bisschen glatt verteilen und
im prinzip kann ich die frucht 1 lag
hier bei raumtemperatur fest werden
lassen bis ihr abkühlt und dann friere
ich sie ein damit sie später einfacher
zu handhaben ist wenn sie nämlich nicht
gefroren ist ist es ein bisschen wacklig
ein spray sie ein damit ich eine
festplatte hat und die dann gut in die
torte bekommen im prinzip muss ich jetzt
warten bis die vorlage kalt ist bis die
tortenböden kalt sind und kann aber dann
in der zwischenzeit so etwa eine stunde
ungefähr bereits die creme zu bereiten
damit wir dann auch bereit ist ok hat
auch gleich bisschen mitdenken können
ich nehme einfach die maschinchen die
haben nämlich einen schönen flachen
boden und eben nicht so eine wahnsinnige
rundung wieder teller
ich setzte es kurzum ich müsste mal
ausprobieren ob die frucht einlage sich
aus dem märchen lösen lässt ohne folie
vielleicht vorher einspielen oder mit
kaltem wasser ausspülen wie bei pudding
das geht ja auch eigentlich ganz gut ich
probier's mal aus und dann beim nächsten
mal ohne
der kuchen ist kalt die waldfrucht
einlagen sind jetzt auch eingefroren ich
mache jetzt hier eine frischkäse
buttercreme ihr könnt aber auch eine
französische buttercreme machen eine
italienische fotograf ist mir ein foto
creme ihr könnt die buttercreme aus der
verpackung nehmen von der coaching
ich nehme jetzt die frischkäse butter
themen weil sie auch recht einfach ist
in der herstellung
wobei ich auch sagen hast ich war kurz
davor die italienische zu machen mit
baiser die ist nämlich auch sehr lecker
ihr könnt euch entscheiden wie ihr
möchtet ihr könnt aber auch eine quad
mascarpone creme machen wie ihr möchtet
ich habe jetzt hier zu gleichen teilen
weiche butter puderzucker und frischkäse
beim frischkäse immer darauf achten dass
es der frisch gesehen doppel ram stufe
ist da muss ich sagen da schwierig auf
philadelphia weil der einfach so den
besten geschmack für kuchen und torten
und krems hat und eben auch die richtige
den richtigen fettgehalt kanäle extrakt
kommt hier auch mit rein und wichtig ist
einfach nur das erst mal die butter
verrühren wird da brauche ich es auch
kein salz denn ich habe den frischkäse
schon salz mit dabei der puderzucker
kommt dazu und man mit extrakt
und dann könnte die zutaten hier schon
mal etwa fünf bis zehn minuten cremig
rühren
[Musik]
und wenn die masse dann weiß cremig ist
kommt der frischkäse dazu ich spürte ihn
nur vorher einmal kurz durch das hat ja
dann nicht blockt das ist so
[Musik]
und das ist im prinzip eine vanilla
buttercreme und ich mache das hier auch
nochmal zitrone
die habe ich ja wie gesagt mal
eingefroren
mit ein wenig zitronensaft damit ist es
noch leckere zitronencreme und dem
restlichen saft nehmen zwar verschlossen
com wer macht das auch immer so beim
salat dressing machen nun doch über
allem gast ohne braucht weil ich kann so
eine an gepresste zitrone ich kann ich
kann das nicht verstehen ich musste dann
fertig auspressen
die nehme ich jetzt auch dann habt ihr
wirklich so von anfang bis ende komplett
verbraucht doch entkernen bekommst auch
in die schule
die creme hatte so die perfekte
konsistenz sie ist schön geschmeidig
stellte allerdings trotzdem ganz kurz in
den kühlschrank damit ich hier aufräumen
kann meint orten werkzeug holen kann
denn jetzt kann die torte gefüllt werden
der kuchen selbst gut abgespült und ich
erst mal das passte denn direkt am
besten ist es wenn ihr so eine torte
packt und praktisch stehen und auch die
frucht füllungen einen tag vorher
zubereitet dann wirklich abkühlen lassen
abdecken und im kühlschrank abkühlen das
nochmal damit der kuchen nicht bröselt
beim schneiden und auch die frucht
einlagen können ja dann auch eben in der
kühltruhe oder im kühlfach einfach
besser abstimmen
ich habe es jetzt natürlich gerade
vorhin erste macht deswegen brüssel
sitzt gleich auch ein bisschen aber es
ist nicht schlimm
es ist nur ein tipp von mir
[Musik]
da die böden durch schneiden entweder zu
zwei oder drei bilden
ich mache jetzt 3
[Musik]
hier schneidet es da oben auch noch den
deckel noch ganz knapp weg denn da ist
mir heute zu bröselig aber ich habe ja
so eine grusel schlüssel dafür creme
münchen
schmeiß ich nicht weg sondern um später
vielleicht nicht ich persönlich aber los
oder jemand anderes kommt weg oder jan
bevor ich da jetzt mit den krümeln an
der oberfläche rummacht schneide ich sie
lieber weg jetzt hier erfasst es mit dem
kuchen nicht mit den krümeln und haben
sie gesagt
ok ich weiß nicht warum aber ich hab'
7000 böden auch mal bis 7 und 6 egal ich
nehme jetzt hier somit eines garching
bord darunter dann hier den ersten boden
da kommt hier drauf und ich habe vorhin
beim backen die backform und klein wenig
kleiner eingestellt als 20 cm damit der
boden jetzt ein bisschen kleiner ist als
dieses geschenk damit ich später beim
bestreiten ist etwas einfacher habt ihr
könnt jetzt ihr müsst aber nichts mit
orten randvolle drumrum legen und einen
tortenring damit ihr das ganze besser
füllen könnt ich lege es gleich darum
aber möchte euch kurz zeigen wie ich
fülle denn sobald wasser blick sieht man
es nicht mehr so gut
das heißt ich nehme jetzt immer ein
bisschen was muss jetzt meine palette
hier
ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen was von der
creme aber erst mal nur ganz wenig die
kommt hier drauf dann lege ich da eine
frucht einlage hinein recht mitic
dann kommt wieder creme drauf und zwar
so dass der rand praktisch hier als das
muss jetzt mit creme aufgefüllt werden
bis hier alles schön glatt ist daher
sollte die auch relativ flach sein wo
ihr könnt jetzt auch noch die böden
gerne mit was trinken
ich muss aber sagen dass der boden schon
recht saftig ist also da braucht man es
wirklich nicht dann kommt hier der
nächste boden drauf und genauso wird die
komplette torte gefüllt ich muss sagen
ich bin mir echt zum fan vom dünnen
tortenböden also ich mag das nicht wenn
der toten wurden so dick es um dann eine
kleine creme schicht dazwischen ist ich
mag es schon wenn es immer so einzelne
kleine geschichten sind vor allem muss
man dann auch um die ganzen
verschiedenen texturen dazu probieren
nicht ein großes stück essen da kann man
wirklich ein kleines stück essen und hat
so gabl vergaben immer alles mit drin
denn hier habe ich auch für ganz zum
schluss auch also auch diesen glatten
boden und alle anderen kommt dazwischen
jetzt nur darauf achten dass es hier
keine beule gebildet wird sondern schön
flach
[Musik]
ich würde euch raten wirklich nur sechs
böden zu schneiden
damit es mit den fruit anlagen passt ich
werde zu einem notgedrungen noch eine
frucht anlage machen müssen
aber ich stelle die torte jetzt schon
mal im kühlschrank sollte die auch
machen
ich stelle hier noch einen tortenring
drumherum damit sie einfach eine schöne
form bekommt und dann sollte sie so etwa
für ein bis zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank damit sie sich später eben
schön auch glatt streichen lässt oder
über nacht abgedeckt im kühlschrank
ich mache noch mal eine frucht anlage
und nochmal buttercreme und schreibe
euch die richtige menge der buttercreme
im block aber die frucht anlage würde
ich so lassen weil ich find fünf stück
sind ausreichend und wie gesagt wenn ihr
die böden richtig schneidet dann warst
doch ich habe jetzt noch mal fruchte
einlagen gemacht ich hätte übrigens noch
einige brauchten eine stoffe vorne
die habe ich nicht gesehen aber ich habe
in dem art und zog direkt auch noch
ausprobiert ob es funktioniert ohne
folie und es geht
ich habe die form vorher einfach
eingefettet mit back trance prill und
guckt mal
es löst sich aus also kann man sich da
die frischhaltefolie sparen und es sieht
nicht so aus aber es ist auch noch
festgefroren
und jetzt kann ich hier die torte
endlich fertig befüllt
ich werde heute allerdings gar nicht
mehr fertig machen sondern sie gleich
abdecken im kühlschrank stellen
dann kann sie ordentlich durchziehen
über nacht und dann kann ich sie morgen
in aller ruhe fertig dekorieren
denn die meiste arbeit habe ich jetzt
schon getan und morgen mache ich dann
noch mal frischen bisschen buttercreme
für den rand
immer mit dem schönsten glatten boden
abschließen
unser konzept den kühlschrank bis morgen
jetzt ist heute der tag für dekorationen
ich habe gestern wie gesagt eine trotten
rand folie trugen gemacht aber das geht
natürlich auch ohne ihr könnt ihr
einfach ein großes torten vom messer
nehmen und daneben den ring ablösen
muss man nämlich ganz gern die folie die
kann nicht abwaschen und wieder benutzen
und jetzt könnt ihr im ersten schritt
einfach mal mit weiterer
buttercremetorte schön glatt streichen
das heißt erstmal eine dünne schicht um
hier diese lücken zu schließen
[Musik]
dann ziehe ich das gerne mit 100 karte
ab dann sehe ich auch wo ich eine
weitere lücke habe und so könnt ihr
jetzt den rand und die oberfläche
retorte schön glas bekommen
[Musik]
bei dieser ersten geschichte habe ich
immer so eine kleine schüssel bei dieser
ersten schicht habe ich immer so eine
kleine schüssel
denn falls da noch kuchen krümmel oder
was aus der inneren füllungen rauskommt
dann habe ich nicht die ganze
buttercreme die dann voller kochen brühl
ist sondern wirklich nur eine kleine
schüssel voll und das auch immer ganz
gut so hier oben dann so nach innen
wegziehen und immer wieder die palette
saubermachen
dann steht jetzt schon mal dick
grundstruktur der torte die stelle ich
kurz in den kühlschrank und werde jetzt
die restliche creme auftragen und
einfärben für die dekoration
[Musik]
ich möchte gleich einen zweifarbigen
verlauf und zwar rosa grün
ich gebe es hier ein bisschen krieger
rhein und nehmen diese lebensmittel
verpassten
ich nehme immer ganz gerne verpassten
und keine flüssige farbe denn flüssige
farbe wird auch die buttercreme
verflüssigen und verändert eben die
textur und verpassten sind ergiebiger
und ich habe hier einfach die deko
farben die sind auch frei von
azofarbstoffen sind überall zugelassen
könnt ihr ganz unbedenklich benutzen
die muss ich noch auf machen und erst
fertig ein bisschen creme mit der
verpasste
[Musik]
ich möchte jetzt auch schöne
pastellfarben daher nicht so viel farbe
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich noch aus rosa und gelb
sondern leicht das auch aus dann kann
ich nämlich noch blüten machen
die cremes fülle ich jetzt in zwei
getrennte spritzbeutel einmal die
posaune einmal die grüne ihr könnt da
auch statt einem spritzbeutel zum
beispiel einen gefrierbeutel nehmen ohne
turner oder falls ihr habt mir ganz
große loch schule oder falls ihr habt es
war ich erst mal zeigen so eine riesige
tülle denn mit so einer großen tüte
könnt ihr praktisch wenn ihr euch jetzt
vorstellt ihr nehmt den spritzbeutel so
könnt ihr die torte im büro im
handumdrehen komplett mit creme
bestreichen
aber ich mache es jetzt ohne denn ich
denke einen spritzbeutel hat jeder zu
hause meiden die spritsorte könnt ihr
auch mehrfach benutzen einfach
auswaschen gut trocknen lassen und beim
nächsten mal wieder verwenden
[Musik]
ich möchte jetzt unten die torte rosa
oben grün
jetzt könnt ihr dem spritzbeutel hier
unten ansetzen und am besten mit einem
drehteller arbeiten und die creme hier
drauf spritzen
einfach bis ungefähr zur hälfte danach
kommt grün und das restliche grün auf
die oberfläche und jetzt nehmt euch am
besten der teig karte die hat er diesen
schönen rechten winkel
und ich hab ja unter der torte mein
garching bord dieses 20 cm bord und die
tories ein stück weit kleiner
das heißt ich kann die teig hatte am
garching dort ansetzen und einem rechten
winkel
die creme abziehen und dann entsteht in
der mitte ein kleiner effekt also mit
verlauf
wenn euch der verlauf noch nicht verlauf
ich genug ist kennt ihr noch mal ein
bisschen grün hier aufs rosa streichen
und hose zum grün und dann einfach
wieder glatt abziehen
[Musik]
und beim allerletzten durchgang wenn der
rand schön ist hier oben wieder glatt
zur mitte ziehen
das muss die oberfläche ist auch nicht
ganz perfekt sein denn da kommt gleich
noch was drauf und die reststrom die
sich jetzt hier so ein bisschen
vermischt hat füllt ihr einfach hier in
so ein spritzbeutel wieder zurück die
torte ständig kurz kalt dass die nicht
warm wird
die brauche ich nämlich gleich als
grundlage für meine blumen ostern ist
deswegen ist gar nicht schlimm wenn sich
da die farben vermischt haben und freue
mich jetzt hier noch kurz auf habe hier
mein orange noch bereit für die blüten
das fühle ich jetzt in einem kleineren
spritzbeutel ich habe da nämlich kleine
köln als kompetent spritzbeutel nehmen
auch einen adapter damit ich die türen
auch während des schwitzens immer wieder
tauschen kann
und hier sind hüllen dabei wie diese zum
beispiel dass es eine blume oder diese
hier ist eine plattitüde
und da fühle ich jetzt im prinzip
verschiedene kleine spritzbeutel und
kann dann gleich diesen blumenkranz noch
machen
[Musik]
jetzt setze ich meine torte um ohne
gagen bord
ich war jetzt hier eine markierung da
könnt ihr auch ein schälchen benutzen da
kommt diese bunt gemischte creme drauf
und zwar ist es eine erhöhung damit ich
da gleich den blumenkranz drauf machen
kann wie bei einem blumengesteck wo
vorher einfach so diese steckmasse drauf
ist dann habe ich hier schokoeier die
benutze ich möchte ich alle habt ihr
diese hob i perlen und zwar sind das so
kurz wie perlen sowie aus dem müssen
könnte jetzt auch eine hübsche idee
kommt und wie gesagt meine ganzen
spritzbeutel mit den verschiedenen tönen
was sie jetzt machen könnt bevor ihr auf
die torte spritze probiert einfach mal
die spritz techniken auf dem teller aus
oder auf einer unterlage und dann könnt
ihr an die torte
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt erstmal ein paar große
blumen und dann kleinere dazwischen und
dann irgendwie noch die eier dazu und
die rebellen dazu es wird
[Musik]
beim absturz bringen noch haus schaut
könnte entweder grüne platte rein
spritzen oder der u wie perlen noch
nehmen
hauptsache man sieht eben diesem
untergrund dann nicht mehr so lastete so
fällt es aber gut
dann freue mich jetzt auf und holt
jemanden zum gucken
[Musik]
ist bereit wird die oster torte wir
schneiden zusammenhang wie so ein
hochzeitspaar über die hand oben hat hat
das sagen tut um einzelfälle so klar hin
willst du noch eine größere torte ich
schneide ich schneide uns mal hier ich
denke halt auch dass so ein stück schon
ziemlich groß ist das muss man sich
schon teil ist gespannt wie es innen
aussieht
rate mal was hat irland für eine farbe
ganz viel frucht geld das vom schönen so
so viel frucht einlagen er langsamer
magst du mont
er krallt sich halt zuerst mal der
schoko ei und da kann ein so halten ihr
so kann man sie besser halten sind dann
muss man sich nicht zu verkrampfen
eine lady schweigt und genießt
doch mal wie schmeckt wie die torte ich
habe noch nichts von dir gehört gut was
bist du keine lady hast du bist nicht
deswegen sagst du denkst eine lady
genießt und sagt wie es ihr schmeckt
also heraus
du bist ein richtig anständiges kind ich
habe das früher auch immer wenn ich
etwas sagen wollte aber ich wollte es
nicht öffentlich sagen habe ich sogar
mein papa sonst geflüster so papa darf
ich was zu trinken haben mit ich glaube
ich glaube mehr als ein schmeckt kriege
ich heute nicht von allein hast du
gesagt das ist köstlich mitteilung
setzen auch unser stück also ich finde
die torte sehr fruchtig nicht so süß
ich habe ja auch keinen zucker in der
frucht füllung sondern wirklich nur die
reine frucht süße von daher passt diese
frucht füllung perfekt zur buttercreme
der mond hyde ist sehr locker sehr
saftig also ich finde die torte alles in
allem geschmacklich und optisch sehr gut
das einzige was mir nicht gefällt
das sage ich euch vielleicht
ursprünglich hatte ich ja die creme
pastellfarben eingefärbt und ich hab
vergessen die farben die farben immer
noch mal ein bisschen nach also die
dunkel nach das heißt am besten macht
ihr euch die farben als cremes kurz den
kühlschrank für 10 20 minuten und dann
seht ihr im endeffekt dass dann die
richtige farbe eben dabei rauskommt weil
ich fand den dicken hella schon bis ein
schöner muss ich sagen das haus oder
einzige kritik muss ich sagen
den papa wird laut probieren lassen
können gab maxime ein stück kuchen
bringen
ok also das rezept findet ihr in meiner
app oder auf sex - blog.de vielleicht
habt ihr lust diese torte so oder
irgendwie anders nach zu backen wie
gesagt könnt ihr sie so hoch backen oder
eben auch ein bisschen größer vom
durchmesser her aber flacher viel spaß
beim backen und habt einen einen schönen
sonntag
sagst du doch laut du also willst du
bringst du mama schlagstock schnick
schnack schnuck schnick schnack schnuck
ela hat gesagt wenn euch das video
gefällt dann lasten like das ist was ist
ein leica apo achim aber unten like also
kanal abonnieren und bewerten ist ein
like sooo und daumen hoch
wow was ich in neun jahren youtube
geschichte noch nie gemacht habe hat er
leichter und labor
[Gelächter]
also macht
[Musik]